hocus pocus do you remember ammulu yes I
do
Sarah Jessica Parker was my one even in
the old makeup mm-hmm well lucky for you
I have some hocus-pocus to news well
it's hard to ignore the public outcry
for hocus pocus I mean it's really hard
to ignore the definite fall for a sequel
et can confirm a script to speed ordered
and a writer is attached for the
upcoming streaming platform Disney plus
best part reportedly they're trying to
figure out a way to bring back the
original Sanderson sisters Sarah Jessica
Parker Bette Midler and Kathy Najimy in
the past Bette has been very vocal about
wanting to get back on the broom I
watched it again and it was so good I
had forgotten how good it was and I was
so impressive it's it's got legs I mean
25 years worth of people watching that's
that's major ET was with the wickedly
good trio in 1993 and hocus-pocus too
just wouldn't be the same without them
[Music]
I've never done a picture with this kind
of special effects with the flying
electricity coming out of your hands
Thank You max for that marvelous
introduction I think that is nothing
short of a genius I really do five years
before Sex in the City
SJP donned a blonde wig and took to the
sky I do my own stunts and this and this
and it's just from great fun but she
wasn't totally on board with the old-age
makeup oh I was horrified and I could
see this places on my face that I'm
gonna need to worry about you know it's
a great lesson in and gravity and what
it really does
[Music]